um so the original title of this talk
was how to teach an old dog new tricks
modernizing a business with data
products but perhaps a more
descriptive title about what i want to
talk about is adapting to the evolving
nature of data products through
governance
and so
like
any good data scientist i want to
give you some context about what i'm
talking about so we'll talk a little bit
about the what why and how of data
governance for folks like yourself data
practitioners and so we'll give some
context around the landscape around data
products and data science
some of the consumer and regulatory
concerns that are cropping up about data
and then finally go through a case study
like a real world case study something
that we went through at mozilla where i
currently work
cool um so before i get started uh i
want to acknowledge my team so the
the
mozilla revenue data team has done like
a ton of work and i would not be able to
give the talk in the way that i can give
it today without their hard work
specifically shen liu and arcadius
kumarzuski
so like sean said i'm a senior data
science and machine learning manager at
mozilla
where i've worked on everything from
metrics revenue machine learning and
data products and subscription services
and then in a past life i worked at
twitter on internet health and safety
and also i've worked in ad tech in a
past past life
and then i guess my final last
background is uh
i would be remiss to say if i didn't say
that we are hiring
so
if you're interested in anything i have
to say um you can go to cruise at
mozilla.org
cool
um so over the past several
years and even more than that we've
really started talking about this notion
of
of data and data products right um so in
dj patil's data jujitsu
he says that a product a data product is
one that facilitates an end goal through
the use of data which is like kind of
like a broad definition but it does give
framing it makes this like a legitimate
thing like a data product is like a an
actual thing not just like some sort of
like notional like concept or
philosophical idea um and then more
recently in the data mesh paper there's
this notion of data as a product and so
it's this idea that like applying data
thinking by the data team to this thing
that you're building right and you have
to think about like this thing that
you're building where you have
stakeholders and customers and these
customers are data scientists ml and
data engineers um and other data
practitioners who are going to be using
this
like thing that you've built and i think
the reason why this is like really
important to point out is that we're
we're at the point now where before
having data products or thinking like
data as a product was a comparative
advantage but we're we're not there
anymore right we've evolved beyond that
as an industry and data is is not just
like an advantage it's like table stakes
to be competitive
so where do we see this in the wild so i
have like four different examples so the
first one is google maps and it is uh
taking us from where we are at the 18t
conference center to interstellar
barbecue the number two barbecue spot in
texas monthly in 2021
and it uses data right it looks at
traffic data at well i guess the time we
took the screenshot which was late at
night i bet it takes longer to get there
and it gives you the end users some
options and like routes you might want
to take right
the next screenshot is of etsy so a
couple months ago was lunar new year and
i was looking at hanbok which are like
traditional korean clothing i didn't buy
them any of them because they're
expensive but etsy sure remembered that
i looked at them and they're offering me
the opportunity to potentially like get
back into that search i was doing to
maybe buy some more
the next one is a screenshot from airbnb
so port aurandis is a beautiful like
coastal town on the gulf coast of texas
it's a place that i've been to
using airbnb before and so they remember
right and wimberley is like a tiny town
in the hill country and if you're
visiting it's a great place if you want
to go for an excursion while you're here
and they're using things like my
geolocation and my past history to like
offer again inspiration for my trip as i
like to call it
the last example is like a different
kind of data product and this is the
firefox data public data report
and this is offering data products as
like metrics and so like it's a set of
like different data visualizations and
like pieces of information the
screenshot that i have here is
the top languages
of firefox desktop users um and
um what i think is like interesting
about this is like when people think
about data products you usually think
about like recommender systems or like
other kind of really interesting machine
learning or ai applications but like
analytics is a very valid and important
data product
so
i've given like talks like this before
um where i talk about kind of like data
science at a high level and i think the
thing that you can say about all data
products is the underlying thing that
ties them it's not just data but data
that has been scienced in some
particular way um but then this gets to
the kind of question of what is data
science right and so you have different
like infographics and like really
beautiful venn diagrams like one of my
favorite representations of this is a
billboard in my daughter's kindergarten
class which is like what do scientists
do and i add some like pretty like big
questions but it was a kind of the
broadest
like generalization i could find that
like sort of fit what i felt like my my
day job was
um
secretly my favorite one is actually
this where they add the load for evil
in defense of my grad school office
he's not evil
um
and also a data scientist
but like if we want to go beyond the
venn diagram and like kind of get like a
little bit more precise like what is
data science so at the end of last year
emily shario uh
gave this really
provocative talk that was titled down
with data science
and i'm not here to defend or refute any
of her claims but one of the things i
think she did that was really
interesting and actually kind of
important was break out the different
kind of functions that like fall under
this like title data science because
it's a pretty big term and so you have
data engineers analytics engineers data
analysts and machine learning engineers
um and i think the thing that like needs
sometimes more love but maybe not to
this crowd
is data analysts or data analytics so
to like show a little love to analytics
like what is it it's insight as output
or you can think about insight as the
product that you're creating as a data
practitioner right um it's very powerful
because you use like analytics to play
the objective voice of your customers or
your users or whatever you're trying to
like characterize with analytics um and
so you have like these metrics or
measurements that you're creating and
your company uses them right to
understand how they're doing to like
view its health right so you're talking
about how like data is no longer a
comparative advantage it's like critical
and having analytics around like the
success of your company is really
important to know how how you're doing
this can look like a variety of
different things it could be opportunity
sizing or like prototyping like new
ideas it could be like causal inference
experimentation stuff it could be impact
analyses for
for whenever
like you can't do an experiment for
whatever reason right um
but what is the secret
to all of these right it's data data
underlies like
like analytics and like all these
data products not even just like in the
analytics case um
but the thing that's happening at the
same time is that consumers and users
are really starting to pay attention to
what companies are doing with their data
right so like a few years ago equifax
which does like credit scores and it you
can compute credit scores with a lot of
really personal and sensitive
information right they had a data breach
and it was like horrible because
potentially 143 million people just in
the us alone which is a lot of people
right um facebook has obviously gone
through issues with cambridge analytica
and like how how data are being used and
like concept flows right um and then you
even have like notions around like like
terms right new terms like surveillance
capitalism right so people every day who
are like having their data like leverage
by different companies for like profit
are really starting to question like
should these companies have my data and
like what are they doing with it
at the same time regulators are starting
to take notice too and so like before i
get into the slide i should say though i
contain multitudes one of them is not
lawyer so if you have more gdpr
questions please find your local
friendly uh jd
um so we all like probably have heard of
gdpr right the general data privacy
regulation um it's part of like the eu's
privacy and human rights laws
and it dictates like kind of and set
standards for how companies
can do stuff with your data if you are
an eu citizen um and so for users it
means that they can know how their data
is used what data companies have about
them they can correct mistakes in their
data and importantly they can opt out
right so there's like consent that is
like a really important part of this
right um
what makes this actually like
enforceable like why do companies have
to pay attention to it there's like huge
fines that are involved with like
violating gdpr and so maybe one strategy
if you're a company could be well i'm
going to ignore the gdpr by like not
serving any customers in europe but the
problem with that is that this is like
the first of many and so even in the u.s
like there's things like the california
consumer privacy act or ccpa
that like is in some ways even more
restrictive than gdpr and like other
even states within the us are coming up
with more
more of these kinds of regulatory
measures and in other regions and
countries too
okay
um so we have this big tension right
between like companies need data to
compete right um but users and
regulators are like hey like why don't
you slow your role and like think about
this like a little more so how do you
overcome the tension and um if you take
away anything from this talk
it's that i like strongly believe that
data governance is data strategy
and so what is data governance um it's
the set of roles policies processes and
technologies that help uh
an organization like
handle its data like in ways that are
like consistent and appropriate and in
compliance um and why is it important as
opposed like because like i i just said
it's like strategy right um but it's
important because it makes sure that
you're complying with all these like
different regulatory like bodies and
make sure that like your data are secure
that you're thinking about data privacy
and not even just data privacy but also
the quality of the data that you're
putting out there and using and trying
to make decisions with um it talks about
things like availability right like if
your data are all over the place like
how does sre help you when everything
falls over
they probably can't and importantly it's
usability so it's like one of the worst
situations to be in is to collect like
piles and piles of data you can't do
anything with right and so you need to
make sure that the data are usable
and at the end of the day i think it
provides like the foundation for a
company's ability to be successful in
its data
strategy so i want to go over
a case study um
that we have
encountered or really gone through lived
through at mozilla so this is something
that we've called the revenue data
access initiative
and in some ways it seems maybe a little
bit different than what i was talking
about because like that was like about
i've been talking about data privacy and
whatnot um but the thing about revenue
data is that it's sensitive and that's
the thing that has in common with like
like data privacy um is that like you
have to be careful on how you handle the
data and very thoughtful right and so we
have this problem statement of like how
do we leverage sensitive data for
insight and understanding um and so
let's let's get into how we thought
about this and how we approached this
issue because what we really wanted to
do is take all of this information
about revenue that we had at the company
that was very sensitive
and really think about it as a data
product
so i think one of the most important
aspects of this whole entire like
project has been this notion of threat
modeling so what is it threat modeling
is this technique that we
often encounter in lake security
where you identify vulnerabilities in
the thing that you're building
while defining solutions to mitigate the
risks right and so what does this mean
for for revenue
data so revenue data um
like what are we building we're really
trying to build this like revenue
analytics data product why because like
revenue data are really important like
they allow us to make better choices
about our business
but like what risk do these bring right
they're really sensitive because a lot
of mozilla's revenue comes through
partnerships with like external
companies and so we have a
responsibility to these companies to
keep confidential information
confidential right um again i want to
point out that it doesn't contain
personal information but it's still like
it's sensitive um and then what are the
things we think we can do to like
mitigate those risks well we need a
system that's designed to do the
following one is only give access to the
people who really need access to the
data
and
once you do have access it needs to be
easy to use right so it needs to be easy
to process to evaluate or to make
decisions from um and again it's like we
want to make sure that like the data are
in the hands only of the people who
really need it due to like the sensitive
nature and like the responsibilities we
have to our partners
so i think that monica rogati's very
famous hierarchy of needs um it's like
kind of like a nice place to like
uh like think about this space so like
it illustrates very cleanly why you
can't go from like zero to gans in the
blink of an eye but i think it's also a
helpful framework for data products so
where are we
um a couple years ago um so
we were really far down on this um on
this triangle um like towards the bottom
it's like we had data they were kind of
all over the place we had some
infrastructure some of it lived in like
real places where you'd want it to live
like a big query type situation and some
of it absolutely did not
and so what we really needed to do with
this initiative was move up this this
triangle
so what was the state of our revenue
data so we had pdfs we had spreadsheets
and we had apis in like the best case
and it was like really exciting when we
had apis um
sometimes these pdfs were like hand
curated from non-mozillians people who
didn't work at the company um
and they they were maintained by
non-technologists so like they're
finance people um like people who like
really needed to have that information
um but because of the sensitivity of it
right like it wasn't given like broadly
uh it was given like to like this kind
of tiny group of people um
sometimes the data lived in emails uh
and not and and if we were lucky
sometimes they lived in box which is
like a storage solution right
um again they're very sensitive data
which is like why they lived in all
these kind of disparate places um
and
where we had it kind of made it such
that you had all or nothing access
and that
could have been okay except once you did
have access to everything it was still
incredibly challenging to use it wasn't
hooked up to like our data warehouse
where like the rest of the data
scientists and data engineers tend to
like work in um and it was something
that like it was just like very hard to
make any insights or get like a lot of
good information off of it because of
like where it lived um and finally like
this is like two cfos ago it was
safeguarded by the cfo herself i was
thinking about
putting a screenshot i have of an email
i have from her that said that i
personally had the authority to make
decisions about who got access to this
data set but again i'm not a lawyer so i
decided to not include that but that's
not scalable right i'm like and and so
we needed to figure out something to to
address this um and so really again at
the heart of this was we needed to start
thinking about revenue data as a product
um so we have a revenue data science
team at mozilla and one of the jokes i
like to make when i'm like recruiting is
it's like it's silly that we have a
revenue data science team because at
most companies you count in the revenue
and like and then you're done you don't
need to have a phd in statistics to
figure this out um but again because
like a lot of our revenue comes from
partnerships like we don't have as much
information
as we possibly want to so there's three
big areas that this team plays in one is
revenue forecasting so we work really
closely with like our partners in
finance to like try to like forecast the
revenue so obviously this means we need
access to revenue data um we also do a
lot of the standard like product data
science work around our monetizable
surface areas and so this would be like
things like a b testing or opportunity
sizing or even just like kind of
defining metrics and trying to
understand user behavior that is either
monetized or monetizable
and then finally this last like kind of
bullet point is like sort of the thing i
want to dig into like a little bit so we
work really closely with the finance and
business operation side of the world um
and
like often there are analysts in this
space um and there are two kind of big
things that we work on with them one is
around methods and the other is around
data access
um so given that this is like what
revenue data science looks like uh what
does a revenue data scientist look like
our data scientist tend to have advanced
degrees um like phds or masters and stem
fields they're really great at sql our
tech stack is bigquery so it's important
um and then also like scripting
languages so like python or our
team's a little split on that um
we also work really closely uh with
finance and business analysts and these
folks are subject matter experts they
know a lot about like business um they
like understand how market trends work
and like you know like what what it
means and how we like they think it will
affect our revenue um in ways that
somebody would say a phd in astronomy
might not know
from their training um they have like
pretty basic sql skills you know like
enough to do like a select star or
whatnot um
they're very proficient in excel um and
you can do pretty straightforward domain
relevant modeling in excel right
oh that got moved there are more
pictures down there
so
in the happy path like the data
scientist helps with advanced
methodology because their phd and stats
like means that they know all these
different techniques that you wouldn't
necessarily expect the finance or
business analyst to know
and then the analysts provide really
valuable domain expertise to like
understand like why like this is just
business logic and you don't have to
stance at it
but it assumes that you have some
foundation that often doesn't exist
around like an easy to
access like data interface um however i
will say in the usual path uh
the scientist has really complicated
data polls for the business analyst to
answer simple questions that in
principle they should be able to answer
themselves um and so
it really i think speaks to the need of
treating revenue data at mozilla as uh
data like data revenue data as a product
right like their stakeholders both on
the data science side and then on the
business analyst side that need to be
able to access and engage with data in a
much more compelling way than we're able
to
so this is where the revenue data access
initiative came in we realized that
there was a big problem and we needed
something to kind of bridge that gap and
how are we going to get around this
we're going to start with
like a data governance framework and so
we have this framework we have like
a policy and then we have some processes
that underlie it
and then
the technical infrastructure that
supports the
these processes um and then we also get
to the point where why are we even doing
this like does it matter are we just
doing this for like to do it but
but like really what we needed was
people needed a visualization layer they
needed to be able to like engage with
the data in a way that was intuitive to
them so that they could make better
decisions
and so we'll step through all of these
here so what is policy policy for us
meant a principal's first approach to
understand who should get access to
sensitive data um and so the way that we
like thought about this is like we had
different categories of data and why
they were sensitive so a category one
this like kind of first level is like
data that was like kind of sensitive but
like you probably couldn't get to the
most sensitive quantities that we were
trying to safeguard category two was
like a little bit more
risky right um it's data that would
allow someone with enough math skills
and like other kinds of information to
back calculate these sensitive
quantities that we're trying to
safeguard and then category three was
like the most highly sensitive the most
restricted data but also the most
interesting right it's the things that
you could actually make decisions about
but again you don't want everybody to
know because we have these
responsibilities to our partners to keep
them like confidential
the next part of this is like who should
get access to this data um and so we
decided on a role-based access paradigm
so we have two types permanent and that
means you have a job where you have to
access revenue data on the regular so
i'm a revenue data scientist and i do
the monthly revenue forecast and so i
need to be able to touch revenue data
right that would be a permanent
type of of access on the other hand we
have project based and so that might be
where you're working on a project that
requires access to these data but there
is like an end date in mind for that
project
and so that could be i'm a data engineer
who's working on a
data connector framework
that like is going to touch a bunch of
different data sources including revenue
data because we want to standardize our
etl
but like so i need to be able to look at
the revenue data to like verify that
like this thing actually worked that
it's plumbed correctly but like after
that i don't need to touch revenue data
um and so it's nice because we have this
like nice little matrix of like what
kind of data do you want and how do you
want to engage with it right but the
thing that's like really important here
is it's not just like the thing that
makes us not ignorable is that like we
need to make sure that it has some teeth
right so people with access to these
data have to understand that they need
to handle these data responsibly that
there is like a lot of different um
like there's a lot of risk writing on
having access to this data
and they need to like have some sort of
way to say that they've acknowledged
that they comply
um and so all of this stuff is like kind
of like a nice like framework or like
high level right but it's like very
philosophical and so
the next kind of like important thing is
like this policy needs to be accessible
by like mere mortals
and so how did we do that at mozilla so
we have a request and evaluation flow
and it starts in everyone's favorite
tool jira right and we use jira as a
paper trail right it's it's a thing that
we can point to and so when somebody
wants access to revenue data they fill
out this template
and it's explaining like who they are
why they want to access what they're
going to do with it what type of access
they want
we then take this to
data access stewards who are the ones
that are in charge of making the
decision so given the information that
the requester has given either they will
or won't get access and then finally
once it's confirmed if somebody will get
access then we leverage google groups
because as i said before we use bigquery
and it's kind of nice because we can use
like the google ecosystem to like
portion out access in in ways that make
sense
um
one of the things that like is maybe a
little bit of a misnomer is like i
mentioned that it's like you can get
permanent access but it's not really
permanent because we do auditing right
so let's say you're a product manager
who's working on revenue
for
like a year but then you're bored and
you're ready to go work on something
else and you've like moved to a
different part of the company you don't
need access to these data anymore so we
do quarterly audits to make sure that
somebody should retain their access and
so in this case we have their manager
request an extension and then we have an
access steward approved
and as we all know
sometimes projects take a little longer
than we think they will right so for
folks with temporary access if you need
this for a project you can again ask for
an extension and like i know i'm getting
into like the nitty-gritty but it's like
i think the thing that people tend to
like kind of like gloss over is like oh
data governance is like really important
which like yes but this is what it looks
like right it's not glamorous um it's
it's kind of like these like questions
that you have to like ask over and over
again so
cool
um
so how do we kind of tie this back to
like it really being a data product um
so the technical infrastructure has
requirements and these requirements are
driven by policy and they have to
support the process um and i think
what's really important like just in
general is that like this kind of like
infrastructure needs to like just be
part of your normal like data
development process like governance
can't be this thing that like happens in
a checklist or like outside or like
whatever right it's like the like if you
have kids like you have to like the
jessica steinfeld method of getting them
to eat vegetables is to blend them into
their food right and so this is like the
jessica seinfeld method of i think
getting people to like really like live
like the ideals of your data governance
um and so for us with this event from a
technical standpoint is we have
differential access implementation um so
only give access to those who need it
and restrict access from those who don't
and we're leveraging bigquery's
authorized views to give differential
access which has been really convenient
for us um and then the other thing too
is like like i said all these data were
in all these different places and emails
and spreadsheets and pdfs um
and like maybe probably some back of
someone's napkin somewhere
and so
we needed to figure out how to get all
the data into like a single place and we
wanted to do this for a number of
different reasons
one was to make the access configuration
like much easier and like tractable
and two
uh we needed to like
like we want to do more stuff with the
data not just like the revenue numbers
but we want to do like like more like
like uh processing and
like other
kinds of manipulations on top of the
data to
make
the data sets more robust and more
interesting
and then finally it's like again
sometimes things fail it's really nice
if you can get sre support you can't get
sre support from like the finance guy's
email right
um
cool
um and so then finally it's like we
worked on the framework we had this
technical thing but like what was the
thing that we're doing um i think it's
kind of funny that in the previous talk
we talked about looker for revenue data
mozilla has chosen looker for our data
visualization layer
and it's been i think really important
for us to do this because liquor in some
ways is like a lot easier for
people who need to make decisions about
revenue data people who want to like
look at metrics like an easy way and
then also people who like can get like
their hands a little bit dirty with data
and maybe they want to do some slices
but like asking a data scientist
repeatedly well can you do this kind of
data can you do that kind of data can
you do this other thing right it ends up
getting like it's like entirely tiring
loop right and so um it's been really
nice because we've been able to leverage
big uh like well yeah i guess bigquery
and its connection into looker
to like provide these kinds of like
dashboards that are interactive for
our stakeholders right and so we're
taking this kind of like stuff that
lived in like emails and pdfs and like
we're able to like
wrangle it in a way such that it's like
it really is a data product because at
the end you're and you end up with
something like this although disclaimer
this is just like a gift from the look
your website because i cannot show you
anything with revenue data in it
um
cool
so um back to this like
hierarchy of needs right so where did we
go in this project like how far have we
gotten um so we're at the point now
where i think we have we have analytics
we have metrics we actually do have
segments which is kind of exciting
because like it's something like we just
hired somebody in february and she like
gave this reporter like i have these
segments and so like we're talking about
how to put them in lookers so that like
our partners in business development can
like play with them right um and so
we're at the point where like all of a
sudden these data are like much more
usable and much more like functional and
it's something where like we can get
deeper insights and we're able to do
more sophisticated analyses on top of
the data too because like they're in a
way that's like tractable and it can
touch the rest of the data warehouse
right so it's been kind of like a really
successful project in that way um we're
obviously not done there's still like a
lot of like there are more data sets
that like we want to import we want to
like empower um even more and a lot of
this is kind of in the previous talker
talking about like you know the lego guy
like what does he want um so we're
talking to our lego people to try to
figure out like what they want and what
is the best way for us to
take these data and like manipulate them
and represent them in a way that is like
the most useful for them
so to kind of like close the loop how
does this
tie back to data privacy uh so like
revenue data and like personal data like
are different domains right but the
thing that they have in common is the
sensitivity like the fact that you
really need to be careful and how you
handle and think about the data um
data that contain potentially like
potentially like sensitive for personal
information is sensitive for different
reasons right
and so the framework that you have to
create is like a policy based technique
of privacy as opposed to the policy that
we use for revenue data is a policy
based on business risk um
the technical infrastructure though
doesn't really have to be
that different right it's still this
notion or in differential access only
people who should have access to the
data like will have access to it um and
again in order to like actually leverage
this data like we want to have it like
in a data warehouse in a place where it
can be supported by sre in a place where
like etls all go and live happily like
ever after right um
and so like in that sense like this was
like a really nice case study for us
even internally to like how can we do
this and how do we scale this out when
we're thinking of not just like
analytics products but also like other
types of data products
and then the empowerment layer again for
revenue data it's insights and then for
like the the more like potentially uh
sensitive data it is insights but it's
also we now have the ability like using
like this kind of framework um you can
you have the ability to like make
user-facing data product um and ones
that are not only like
interesting because of like the
technical like underpinnings and
whatever but also interesting because
they're ones that like are very
respectful of your users
um so i guess that's it i guess like the
three big takeaways are having data is
not a luxury but rather a necessity data
governance is data strategy um and
incorporating data governance into like
sort of the day-to-day of how your
organization like does business or
thinks about data
and making these processes accessible to
like everyone are critical to actually
get people to adopt these practices and
then my like secret bonus one is don't
sleep on analytics
thanks
[Applause]